what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was in
a small town in Costa Rica Pura Vida and
was eating some sort of delicious fish
and I received a call and it was my
agent
he was very panicked and he said I have
Zack Snyder on the phone he wants to
talk to I don't know why Barry Allen
Bruce Wayne you said that like it
explains why there's a total stranger
sitting in the dark in my second
favorite chair and then Zack Snyder came
on the phone you think I'm a big fan
you're working with people with special
abilities stop right there
I'm in and I started having
[Music]
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was
meeting with Zack and he actually had a
chance to see all the concept art and
all the stuff and basically he was like
you know I want to pitch his idea but
basically if you want to know what we're
doing we're doing this he took out the
dislike sculpture from The Dark Knight
for the Frank Miller book of Batman and
Superman fighting I was like I am the
luckiest guy in the world Batman is the
coolest part in any universe playing
well with others again
just like a bad dig may be temporary
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was in
an airplane just landed and then I got
the call and then I started screaming in
the middle of the airplane
[Music]
[Music]
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was in
my apartment and I got a random call
from Zach's assistant saying hey is that
one to talk to you briefly hell is like
oh he's probably just calling me to tell
me I'll well thanks but you know we're
going in a different direction he gets
on the phone he's like so looks like
we'll be making a movie and I go I'll
take it from here
do I know you
what were you doing at the moment when
you found out you got the role I was in
mr. Snyder's office and he's going I
want you to play someone for me he goes
Aquaman and I'm Mike pardon me that was
the biggest shot in my life
[Music]
[Music]
what we're seeing is a crime wave
[Music]
what did you do this weekend I know me
her nothing very interesting
now protective gear
[Music]
new lanterns
Oh Kryptonian
[Music]
was really for
like all the others but misses the days
where mom's biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguins
this is crazy fighting the devil in his
army you know
don't engage alone little this together
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff I've never done
battle just relax Alfred I'll take it
from here uh do I know you
[Music]
as a beginner to the world
[Music]
he didn't just save people you made to
see the best parts of the south
as well
we don't have to recognize them
you just have to save it
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think that oh wow they just
they really just vanish
oh that's rude
[Music]
you said you've come now let's hope
you're not too late
you